i think
being adaptive being
someone who's able to pivot in different
situations and
can kind of thrive in in different
environments that's something that i
always wanted for myself i couldn't say
before i moved to israel that that was
me right and now i feel i'm in a much
better place to say that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i'm joined by aaron bors the vice
president of marketing at hiro where he
has helped lead the company from
pre-seed to series a since 2019.
he has over seven years of business
development marketing and product
experience mainly within emerging
technologies such as conversational ai
prior to hiro aaron helped develop and
launch duplex at google which broke
boundaries in the natural language space
and started his career at checkpoint
helping to grow enterprise mobile
security aaron completed a ba in
business administration at idc arts leah
with a specialization in marketing after
serving in the idf's gewati brigade as a
lone soldier when out of the office
you'll get his attention with hosting
events good b2b branding and the new
york knicks
aaron bores welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me from
israel how are you
doing great happy to be on the show
thanks for inviting me
it's going to be a great great show
talking about
journeys and non-conventional journeys
um
really um you know the place that you're
at today you know working on some of the
most fascinating projects uh vp
marketing at hiro an amazing startup in
this really good system but previously
having worked at some fantastic
organizations and obviously the coolest
product in the world google duplex i'm
i'm unbiased of course
and and um but doing all that with a
really
unconventional
personal journey
that that most people around the world
definitely don't experience and so i'm
looking forward to sort of stitching
your story together and sort of drawing
this line and connect the dots with your
theme and so um welcome to the show and
i'm excited to hear your story
thank you so much i i hope it'll be uh
as interesting
as you might uh you might expect i for
me the story of how i came to israel is
uh very
similar to a lot of other stories of
lone soldiers so
um
you know but to the rest of the world i
guess it seems insane right that someone
would pick up leave the united states
come to israel and join a foreign
body of military so i'm happy to jump in
and and start talking about the the
story with you today with yes and thanks
for having me
all right let's do it take me back
take me back sort of to growing up
because even the the this decision to
pick up and leave and
you know you're going to a different
setting a military setting i mean that's
that's kind of wild right i mean most
people you know they don't say you know
let me let me just go and list
in a military in a country where i don't
necessarily speak even fully the
language
correct um i don't i don't think it's an
easy decision whatsoever it's made
easier by circumstances so if
everything's going really well it's it's
an interesting concept right if
everything's going really well um in
your home country you might not pick up
and leave and have this adventure i get
to experience the types of
um you know uncomfortable uh
scenarios challenges etc that come with
these
types of big moves um
so i was lucky enough that at around age
19 i was uncomfortable i was
uncomfortable in a college setting in
the u.s i didn't feel that
higher education made sense at that
point having not experienced really
any kind of life uh you know experience
that would kind of shape me and and make
me understand where i'd want to take
myself down the road so um
there were a lot of reasons that
culminated together
that really helped me to understand that
israel was the place for me and
specifically the idf was the right
chapter for you know that time period in
my life and
i'll say that i grew up you know in long
island surrounded
by
quite a dense jewish population
i grew up in great neck new york so even
going to public school felt almost like
yeshiva uh you know it uh it was very
rare someone didn't understand what
jewish holidays were even not being from
uh you know that religion and um growing
up in that community gave me a very
strong sense of
identity towards judaism but also
towards israel um the israel parade the
you know constant
activities whether it was through hebrew
school or just in great neck in general
in the various community centers that
were set up
right so all that kind of pours together
to create the strong identity um and the
strong affiliation with israel my
parents also met in israel neither of
them were israeli but they met in israel
and
and so
you know that really shaped the decision
i think to to focus on israel as a place
of of growth for myself and yep i did
that right after high school so
um it's really easy to join the israeli
army i don't know if people know how
easy uh you make they make you sign a
few forms um and then uh sure enough
they just hand you
uh an automatic rifle no i'm kidding but
all you need is a
really
to prove that you're
from judaism and show that you're going
to stay in israel and you can go through
muffler green sabar
and that's how i became a lone soldier
so uh i came
really for two major reasons one was to
defend um the nation of israel which uh
which is dear to my heart and the other
was to
was to grow to
find out you know what's in my core and
um and and what am i really about
beautiful and then obviously you know
the israeli the israeli military with
with its compulsory service it does a
phenomenal job at
taking people of all backgrounds and all
stories um and and sort of leveling the
playing field and and you know with
training and with social conduct and
with sort of this community idea i
remember in an as an officer myself you
know we learn this phrase um army builds
nation builds army or maybe nation
builds army builds nation but there's
this idea that we all come together we
get this training and we get this
maturity mature
journey together and we grow but
going back once again this decision to
pick up and leave and to transition to
change
right i mean you're you're in the us
you're in the college system which is
you know
very structured you know you're doing it
with the peers that you've known and or
you're getting to know that you've had
similar lives and you sort of one day
say you know what i'm doing something
different i'm actually going in a
different life path
that can't be a trivial decision can you
go back like what how do what gets to
that conviction at the end it's a
dramatic decision
well i think
i think there there's some impulse to it
but it's definitely something that
builds over time right so it's not as if
i just picked up and left right after
high school so
i decided to do a year of college i
decided to see if that was the right
path for me and after two semesters or
you know around
12 months instead of graduating high
school i understood that
um i was doing something unpopular
seemingly disastrous towards that track
right americans
often not just americans
but
mostly americans uh put you on this
track where if you get off the track
it's going to be very hard to catch up
everyone's going to keep moving at that
same pace if not faster and if you get
off the track my god what's going to
happen to me i'm going to be behind i'm
going to right now be as successful as
my friends who are now a couple of feet
or meters or whatever it is ahead
um
so it's a difficult decision of course
it's challenging decision and each step
of the way in the army watching friends
either get internships in fancy you know
companies uh
merrill lynch or whatever it is in the
united states watching friends become
you know the president of their
fraternities those things
the challenge it's challenging to see
that happening and feel a little bit of
fomo at the same time
you know the trade-off is
that i'm i'm doing something real and
impactful on a level that i just
couldn't find in the in the us at the
time um at least that doesn't relate to
my beliefs there's nothing wrong with
joining you know the american military
or doing other great programs or uh
finding different ways to give give back
through uh
through you know other channels or
agencies but for me doing it for israel
was the only way to do it um
and again i think it's a it's a
culmination of factors right so
right place right time uh right mindset
uh especially
i think mindset is is key there a lot of
people will join the israeli army
volunteer in the israeli army um lone
soldiers will come escaping something i
think that's wrong i think uh most of
the lone soldiers that i've seen who
have either abandoned their service in
the middle or who have high-tailed it
back to their uh country of origin right
after their service they're doing that
because they came here with the wrong
mindset so
um either it was something where they're
running away from a home or some
problems at home or
you know they're
the best way to do it is to run towards
something so i think if your intentions
are are pure to join the idf and
um you know you're coming here for the
right reasons it's gonna work out and
for me again those intentions were
make a um
make a better um
uh core and understand my values more
and grow as a person as a man and then
the second part was let's you know i
want to defend this country it means the
world to me amazing
so
post army you're you're in israel you're
simulating to sort of the culture here
in the industry here
how what what path sort of takes you
into into product and into marketing
yeah it's a great uh it's a great
question uh all roads lead to high tech
if you live in tel aviv no just uh
it's just
seriously
yeah it's um it's really easy as an
international to slip into high-tech
right like um it's much less common that
i'll take my mediocre hebrew and go
towards being a lawyer where i have to
potentially stand in court and argue
with the native speaker every day um so
yeah i think
that the skill set obviously helps um
but i'll just say that after i
graduated or sorry after i finished my
service in the idf so i did take some
time to understand what i wanted to
study and i was in a much better place
to know that what i was actually going
to study is what i was going to do
so i went to
now it's called reichman university but
at the time it was idc herzeglia
and i studied marketing in business
i did that in
an amazing program uh graduated in 2015
lucky enough that i was with
just a fantastic
uh array of different people from
different countries different worlds um
when i graduated i knew that i wanted to
um to take marketing and do something
with it immediately and and that's what
tech opened for me so that door to tech
was actually for me a door to marketing
and i took an interesting way to finally
get to where i needed to be which is as
a marketing executive leading a team
which is always kind of the vision right
um but yeah i started a checkpoint that
was more of a biz dev role then moved to
google in a product development role for
google duplex which is how i found
conversational ai
uh and then ultimately i uh
landed hiro and um started as head of
marketing and have built myself up to
to now
have a team of 11 and well
vp marketing at the company so
um
yeah that's that's the journey
so far and it really my main point is
it's not a straight line right yeah i
went in different paths
i wanted to understand sales more so i
started in something that was more biz
dev oriented and i wanted to understand
product more
uh so i went to a role that wasn't
necessarily my calling but something i
knew would give me a skill set that i
could use in other areas once i became a
marketer now i have a fantastic
relationship with our product team i
think in a product oriented way um so
yeah just
saying that for anyone listening who
thinks that because they're in one
discipline they can't break into another
that's
you know that's horse crap yeah pardon
my
language so
i'm focusing on the mindset a little bit
so
you know if we're looking at sort of
decision making as an idea and
open-mindedness to
to change in transitions or or having
and having the confidence to do so
do you see sort of this
do you see that the similarity between
a decision like
you know
transitioning countries and enlisting in
the idf to transitioning from from
product to marketing or taking those
leaps of faith even within your
positions is that something that's sort
of repetitive
yeah for me as a person absolutely i
think um being adaptive being um someone
who's able to pivot in different
situations and
can kind of thrive in in different
environments that's something that i
always wanted for myself i couldn't say
before i moved to israel that that was
me right and now i feel i'm in a much
better place to say that who knows i'm
still young i'm 32 so time will time
will tell how much uh pivoting and and
and uh yeah different moves i'll make
but um absolutely i think being adapted
is super important uh especially in tech
where people can easily find themselves
in a role they don't love 15 years down
the road yeah
you know
snap of the fingers it's it's
you know and i think now you see that
people are starting to gravitate towards
testing the waters a little bit more and
that's why
you know resumes the average uh
average amount of time spent in a job in
tech is going lower lower and lower
that's a huge headache as a manager but
i totally understand why the average
employee is doing that um because it's
becoming more common to be adapted to
know that you have value to test the
waters based on that value and see where
you're going to thrive which hats look
great on you and which hats you should
probably take off all of that's coming
from a ton of different you know
swinging from job to job
from a niche you know a niche
um
a niche like fintech to a niche like
agrotech to a niche like food tech i
mean
um it's a it's a wide wide world and i
think people are exploring it fantastic
and so tell me a little bit about about
hiro and
your role as vp marketing what what is
sort of your position within this
conversational ai space
sure so um i'll just give one sentence i
guess about uh jairo so
we think that chatbots and ivrs suck um
the way that they're deployed is wrong
uh they're built on this inherently
but flawed architecture
called intense so if x then y if michael
says red then go if michael says green
then stop we know conversations don't
work that way so hiro's creating what's
called adaptive communications
and we deploy conversational interfaces
that are able to scale with enterprises
based on a totally different modality so
that's hyrule in a nutshell we work with
massive us enterprises in order to do
that um and i've been with the company
from its inception so i hopped on board
when they had like i don't know
michael maybe it was three hundred
thousand dollars in pre-season funding i
don't even think i checked to be honest
i
i was was
uh really enamored with
the idea but also the people the
co-founders are what i bet on it's all
about people at the end of the day
and the co-founders very quickly
convinced me that with their leadership
and the technology this would be a
successful venture
so i left the google duplex team which
was conversational in the eye as well
and i i moved into hiro his head of
marketing but to be honest i was a
glorified bdr i was a glorified qa
engineer i was a glorified uh ae i mean
i i
wore every hat that was humanly possible
for the first 10 months while i was the
only non-uh tech person wow
um
and that was a lot of fun really big
headache but a lot of fun
and that's how also you discover okay
all these facets of the startup you know
how everything ticks how everything
comes together and then you can be
better in your job when you do that
because you understand the mindset of
everyone around you uh so i i'm in the
head of the product person because i was
him once even on a small scale but i was
him once and and uh the person who's you
know leading partnerships oh i did her
job at some point you know and so um
so i think joining startups that early
it gives the most challenge you can ever
ask for but ultimately it you know it
makes you that much more collaborative
at the end of the day interesting really
really interesting
conversational ai is a space
so kind of you know your thinking
process around
you know strategy
what are the different
what what are the different you know
content points of contention maybe from
consumer behavior or or big mindset
shifts that consumers need to make in
order to
really adopt this be this this
technology into their lives sort of
where we are today and what are what how
do you see you know then the main way
that hiro is integrating into that space
yeah so the adoption for a
conversational reality is already
happening
um and i have to say it's one of the
it's a pro and a con for hyrule right so
we're in a red ocean everyone
understands that the adoption's
happening and there's a ton of chatbots
voice assistance virtual assistants ai
assistants whatever you want to call
them there's a million uh terms what's
uh what's going on um but it's it's
happening it's been happening for the
last five years you see the adoption so
of americans were using digital
assistance on a monthly basis this was
uh about two years ago that number is up
to no 33
sk it's slated to grow to 40 percent um
so you see that there's mass adoption
right that's that's uh that's the case
where we are already experiencing most
of us some kind of interaction with a
virtual assistant or digital assistant
um quite quite frequently so that's the
issue i think is not in the adoption
it's now in
polishing the experience so
you know amplifying that customer
experience making it more
consumer-centric
um
you know really trying to fix a lot of
the issues that have existed
based on antiquated technologies so chat
bots chatbots technically came out you
know 30 years ago you had a chat but it
was awful but you had one and now you
have you know today hundreds of chatbots
that are
based on today's standards just
just also not living up right they don't
meet that bar that quality bar um so i
think that's going to be the major
uh major hiccup for a lot of these
companies and also skip being scalable
so you know intent based trying to build
conversational flows it doesn't work we
know it doesn't work
um google duplex was the most
sophisticated incredible conversation i
still is uh to date it was
able to pass the turing test in a lot of
ways for specific use cases there was
under a 1 detection rate for the fact
that you were speaking to an ai
assistant which is incredible right uh
but that was only for specific use cases
was actually for one use case to start
we're talking about you know how do you
scale that though how do you scale that
without dedicating one project for you
know the span of 18 months just on that
one use case um and so
that's that's you know those are going
to be the two issues how how high of a
quality mark can you set and how well
can you scale that and whoever's gonna
do that first and prove that it works
it's gonna it's gonna take 100
aaron this was so enjoyable and awesome
amazing journey um from
from lone soldier to today vp marketing
with with incredible background and
experiences in between but but also
working on probably the most exciting
field in in tech today at least in my
opinion that will literally change how
we are we're interacting with the world
and with technology in general so thank
you very very much for your time and for
your energy and um and best of luck with
hiro and then and the future journey and
i look forward to keeping in touch
thanks so much michael this was a big
pleasure and uh yeah hiro's hiring so if
anybody out there it's uh looking for
jobs right here uh no but really thank
you thank you
you